今天要來當沖
3231的緯創
速度10倍
特別注意
今天手機不在我手上
今天所有教學內容
不是推薦個股
更沒有進出場建議
所有投資都有風險
一定要評估自己
是否有辦法承擔
準備好了
我們當沖開始
Go!!!
老師我很害怕
不會啦
你想要做多還是做空？
還是你要等到
看一下再決定
我要...
我看也看不懂
我看多好了
看多 好
看多最簡單了 你要...
都還沒開始
均價線的方向
什麼均價線...
均價線有沒有
一條線啊
或是看那個
我知道!你上次教的
這裡
對對對對
比如說現在股價
167.5
然後它比它高
你就是偏多嘛
有沒有
它均價167.9
現在171
做多嘛
比它強啊
啊我怎麼下單？
哇...沒救了...
連手機app都...
一定要了...
了解自己的下單媒介
下單
欸對
買進
好確認
這樣是對的嗎
啊但是沒有點到
因為它一直往上拉
欸！成交
買進 來
你想要賺多少？
2000嗎？
呃
好啊
你可以掛好
壓力就直接出掉
或是那個
或是繼續判斷下去
都可以啊
你剛成交171.5
所以你可以找一下
它的壓力有沒有
看一下壓力
我知道我知道
沒有壓力
沒有壓力就可以
回去有沒有
沒有壓力就
不要去預設立場
直到它
新的壓力出現再說
啊沒有壓力
你就可以
看剛那條線
如果跌破
就代表它轉弱了
或是它繼續
有沒有過高
你看有沒有過高
像早上174
如果174沒有再過
代表它
高不過高
就可以怎麼樣？
出掉了
對
啊如果有再過高呢？
就繼續抱
或是達到你的目標
你一天夢想
想要賺多少錢
5000塊
好 你剛買171.5
你要賣176.5
你就可以
先掛好也可以
掛不用錢嘛
下去了...
我不會看啊
什麼線？
線在哪？
啊這個 K 線也沒有
什麼壓力區什麼
第三章第一節 均價線
一定要學會判斷
線 真的很重要
好不好
真的餒
怎麼辦啊
選到紅線
月老會幫你牽姻緣
看均價線
股價會幫你賺錢
你看
均價線就是這條
有沒有
代表今天所有人的
平均成本
啊股價在均價線之上
代表今天人都？
很強
賺錢 對
賺錢就不用害怕
啊如果它跌破
你就要小心了
代表它轉弱了
你做多就要小心了
那怎樣能看
我就在這邊等這樣？
你可以
選擇我們教的...
看5分K
或是看均價線
都可以啊
那我看5分K
也不一定看得懂
像5分K
第一根就是很長
代表
大家都買進去
才會長紅棒嘛
你的176快到了
要不要先掛？
好啊
來 趕快先掛
我會我會
你想要掛
賺5000塊嘛
賣出
啊沒有你要()*#$&_)R#
你要價格啊
176先選一下
這樣
啊也是限價？
欸對
賣出
確認
好
你也可以不要理它
然後就
聊天聊天
聊著它就出去了
欸我蠻厲害的
欸就出去了
欸我很厲害
結束了
這檔股票它是一個
創高的走勢
因為看60K
它就是一個
一直往上
而且有越過前高
代表沒有壓力嘛
啊沒有壓力的話
我們也做多為主啊
啊做多就很簡單
看你要看那個
江波圖的均價線
或是看那個
5分K的壓力支撐
像它支撐第一根就
往上衝
然後這位同學也
很快就買進去了
啊買進做多的話
就以支撐為主
支撐沒有破
你就不要緊張
做對勇敢抱下去
甚至積極一點
做對敢加碼也可以
我過去用很多種
當沖方法
我把最好用的幾招
整理起來叫做
當沖7大獲利術
每一招
我都研究出
最好的買賣方式
真的可以做到
勝率又高
賺的又多
賠的又少
這7大獲利術
我都有放在我的
線上直播講座裡
點連結就可以免費報名
之前有很多學員
學完前面七招
再來看我當沖影片
獲利突飛猛進
每天都能賺個
3000-7000塊不等
甚至還有上萬塊的
講座名額有限
如果點進去沒看到場次
就代表暫時額滿了
趕快把握機會
點連結報名
我們來看一下
同學的成績
老師我很幸運耶
隨便亂點
這不是幸運啊
不是喔？
你看喔
假設機率是
漲或跌50%50%
那我問你
假設你多一個判斷條件
喔 你變成60%了
如果你有兩個條件
變成70%
是不是勝率就更高了
但是很多人就是
50%50%去賭而已啊
因為我不會啊
就隨便選一個
OK
（軟體顯示錯誤）
沒有達成目標